Märkte und aufgrund von technischen
Problemen dort in Berlin konnten wir das
zunächst nicht übertragen aber wir
schalten uns jetzt in die laufende
Befragung der Bundesregierung ein und
zwar sowohl hier im Plenum als auch im
Ältestenrat im Kern geht es um die Frage
ob unsere Geschäftsordnung überhaupt
weitere Wahlvorschläge zulässt
§ 2 unserer Geschäftsordnung spricht im
Zusammenhang mit dem zweiten und dritten
Wahlgang von weiteren Bewerbern das
stimmt diese Vorschrift ist jedoch nicht
anwendbar sie gilt nur für den Fall
dass der Stellvertreterposten keiner
bestimmten Fraktion zusteht und alle
Fraktionen für diesen Posten
Wahlvorschläge einreichen können das ist
in der Wahl in dieser Wahlperiode nicht
der Fall wir haben zu Beginn der
Wahlperiode beschlossen dass es nur
fraktionsgebundene Stellvertreterposten
gibt
dementsprechend ist das
wahlvorschlagsrecht jeder Fraktion auf
das ihr zustehende Präsidiumsmitglied
beschränkt in diesem Fall ist es
unzulässig dass die
vorschlagsberechtigte Fraktion weitere
Bewerber für ihren Stellvertreterposten
vorschlägt denn sonst könnte eine
Fraktion die Wahl ihres Kandidaten im
dritten Wahlgang über das Meer
meiststimmenprinzip erzwingen das wäre
mit der verfassungsrechtlich
gewährleisteten freien Wahl der
Vizepräsidentin und Vizepräsidenten
nicht vereinbar daher kommt auch die
aufsetz ein weiterer Wahlvorschläge auf
die Tagesordnung nicht in Betracht
um auch hier im Hause diese Frage
endgültig zu klären werde ich daher den
für die Auslegung der Geschäftsordnung
zuständigen Ausschuss mit den
aufgewogenenworfenen Fragen befassen und
ich denke dass das auch in Ihrem
Interesse ist dass sich der Ausschuss
noch mal damit befasst und ich gehe
davon aus dass die anderen Fraktionen
hier im Hause nichts dagegen haben dass
sich der Geschäftsordnungsausschuss
damit noch mal befasst
ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
jetzt stimmen wir aber noch mal über die
von den Fraktionen der spd-cdu/csu
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und die Linke
vorgeschlagene Tagesordnung ab wer
stimmt für diese Tagesordnung
wer stimmt dagegen
dann ist die Tagesordnung so beschlossen
Enthaltung entschuldigung habe ich noch
kurz gefragt sehe ich nicht dann ist die
Tagesordnung gegen die Stimmen der
afd-fraktion so beschlossen jetzt rufe
ich auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 1
Befragungen der Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung hat mitgeteilt dass
heute der Bundesminister für Ernährung
und Landwirtschaft Herr Jam Özdemir zur
Verfügung steht Herr Bundesminister sie
haben das Wort für ihre einleitenden
Ausführungen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in diesem Haus
stehen wir fortwährend vor der Aufgabe
und Pflicht sowohl die gegenwarts als
auch der Zukunft gerecht zu werden dabei
geht es mehr denn jeder darum unsere
natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen zu schützen
und damit nicht nur wir sondern auch
künftige Generationen in Freiheit leben
können so trägt es uns das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in seinem
wegweisenden Urteil vom März 2021 auf
man kann es aber auch anders formulieren
es geht darum die Schöpfung zu bewahren
um die Zukunft zu gewinnen so der
bemerkenswerte Titel der
Regierungserklärung
ich weiß nicht ob es jemand weiß von
Helmut Kohl vor 35 Jahren
die Herausforderung der Gegenwart und
Zukunft gleichermaßen gerecht zu werden
stellt sich natürlich auch und in ganz
besonderen Maße für unsere
Landwirtschaft und das gleich darauf
komme ich in der landwirtschaftlichen
Tierhaltung der Veränderungsbedarf ist
immens wie uns auch die gesellschaftlich
breit besetzte und weithin über
Parteigrenzen hinweg anerkannte Borchert
Kommission eindrücklich bestätigt hat
die notwendigen Veränderungen müssen
jetzt angegangen und nicht auf die lange
Bank geschoben werden eine zukunftsfeste
Tierhaltung ist erklärtes Ziel dieser
Bundesregierung erstens können und
müssen wir schaffen dem Wohl der Tiere
in den stellen und auf der Weide besser
gerecht zu werden sie sind schließlich
unsere Mitgeschöpfe zweitens ist
hierhaltung nur dann zukunftsfest wenn
Sie mehr als heute zum Schutz von Umwelt
von Natur und von klimabeiträgt und
drittens geht geht es darum dem
erklärten Wunsch der Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher nach mehr Transparenz
beim Einkauf nachzukommen sie wollen
wissen wie das Tier gelebt hat dessen
Fleisch auf ihre Teller kommt und
schließlich geht es bei all dem um
bessere Perspektiven für unsere
Bäuerinnen und Bauern sie brauchen
Planungssicherheit und sie brauchen
unsere Unterstützung um in ihre Höfe zu
investieren und Sie verdienen ein gutes
Einkommen für ihre harte Arbeit auf die
unsere Gesellschaft dringend angewiesen
ist
die Bevölkerung fordert mehr
tierschützen mehr Tierwohl sie fordert
mehr Qualität mehr Klimaschutz des
kostet aber eben dann auch seinen fairen
Preis damit Landwirte und Landwirte sich
das leisten können wenn wir diesen Preis
nicht zahlen dann mag das Fleisch jetzt
doch billig sein aber damit wird es
perspektivisch keine Tierhaltung mehr in
Deutschland geben dann werden die
tierhaltenden Betriebe dicht machen weil
sie weder in einem ruinösen Wettbewerb
bestehen können noch dauerhaft gegen das
Klima und die verbraucherwirtschaften
können deshalb ist es jetzt unsere
wichtigste Aufgabe dafür zu sorgen dass
die notwendigen Investitionen auf den
Höfen unterstützt werden das mehr
Tierwohl beim Verkauf der Produkte für
die VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher auch
sichtbar wird und das insgesamt
Verlässlichkeit und Planungssicherheit
für die Landwirte den Landwirte einkehrt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
der umfassende Kontext in dem wir
intensiv daran arbeiten die Anleitung
mit vier Maßnahmen zukunftsfest zu
machen erstens haben wir einen Vorschlag
für ein staatlich verbindliches
tierhaltungskennzeichen eingebracht das
verlässlich transparent schafft und die
Leistungen der Landwirten und Landwirte
sichtbar macht zweitens geht es um
Anpassung im bauerngenehmigungsrecht
damit die Fläche sich an die Tiere
anpasst und nicht umgekehrt drittens
geht es darauf aufbauend um bessere
Regelungen beim Tierschutz und nicht
zuletzt braucht es jetzt eine
Unterstützung der Landwirtinnen und
Landwirte bei Investitionen die Zukunft
ihrer Höfe uns beim laufenden Betrieb
damit der Wandel sich dann schließlich
irgendwann selber tragen kann all diese
Maßnahmen tragen dazu bei die
Tierhaltung in Deutschland zukunftsfest
zu machen man kann es auch
zusammenfassen eine Investition in eine
zukunftsfeste Tierhaltung sie nützt
erstmal den Bäuerinnen und Bauern sie
nützt den Tieren sie nützt dem Klima sie
nützt den verbraucherschützerinnen
Vertrauen und Verbraucherin sie stärkt
die Gegenwart als auch die Zukunft
unserer ländlichen Räume wofür nicht
wovon nicht nur zur Wirtschaft
profitiert sondern schließlich auch man
kann so pathetisch sagen unsere
Zivilgesellschaften unsere Demokratie
wir können mit einer vertretbaren
Investition so viel gleichzeitig
erreichen wir sollten diese große Chance
gemeinsam beim Shop verpacken und mit
einer guten Politik Gegenwart als auch
zukunftsgerecht zu werden wenige
Generationen von Menschen sind jetzt
gerade dabei das Gesicht dieser Erde auf
Jahrtausende hin zu verändern
früher Anwender gesagt wir sägen an dem
Ast auf dem wir sitzen mittlerweile sind
wir dabei die Wurzel des Baumes zu
zerstören von der wir alle leben wir
müssen unsere Bäuerinnen und Bauern
dabei unterstützen die Wurzel dieses
Baumes zu hegen und zu pflegen um unsere
Nahrung und unsere Zukunft sicher zu
machen vielen Dank
vielen Dank wir beginnen nun die
regierungsbefragung zu den einleitenden
Ausführungen des Bundesministers und zum
Geschäftsbereich sowie zu den
vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzung und
allgemeinen Fragen das Wort hat zuerst
aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion Albert Stegemann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Herr Minister das waren viele Bilder
wenig Konkretes leider aber nun eine
konkrete Frage die Bürger in diesem Land
machen sich große Sorgen das Thema
Inflation schlägt um sich wir alle
verbinden es zunächst mit den
Energiekosten aber wir sehen die letzten
statistischen Erhebungen zeigen uns dass
wir bei den Lebensmittelpreisen bei
22,3% sind also die Lebensmittelpreise
folgen den Energiepreisen bei diesem
Thema auch bei diesem Thema habe ich sie
bisher leider überhaupt nicht vernommen
und sie waren komplett unsichtbar vor
einigen Monaten hatten sie jedoch mal
einen Vorschlag gemacht und den will ich
noch mal aufgreifen dass sie in Erwägung
ziehen die Mehrwertsteuer auf
Lebensmittel abzusenken ich habe seit
Monaten von diesem Vorschlag nichts mehr
gehört und ich frage sie jetzt konkret
wie weit sind Sie in Ihren Überlegungen
dieses konkret umzusetzen
vielen Dank für die Frage ich habe den
Vorschlag deshalb nicht mehr wiederholt
weil er erkennbar keine Mehrheit hat und
ich bin ein koalitions dienlicher
Abgeordnete wir brauchen Mehrheiten für
die Dinge die Bundesregierung hat sich
zu Recht auf Dinge verständigt die jetzt
unmittelbar Entlastungen mit sich
bringen muss das nicht alles ausführlich
zitieren sie kennen die
entlastungspakete eins und zwei die
konkrete Entlastungen beinhalten ob es
die Entfernungspauschale ist ob es der
grundfrei Betrag ist ob es der
Heizkostenzuschuss ist ob es der Wegfall
der EEG-Umlage ist aber ganz
entscheidend jetzt das dritte
Entlastungspaket und da lege ich sehr
viel Wert auf weil das sind viele Dinge
drin die auch unsere Landwirte Landwirte
entlassen und das sind viele Dinge drin
wenn Sie die Energiepreise helfen zu
deckeln und zu reduzieren hoffentlich
auch Auswirkungen haben auf die
Einkaufspreise also das Beispiel dass
Sie angesprochen haben wenn wir es
schaffen bei den Energiepreisen
runterzugehen hat das auswirken und
sagte zweite Auswirkung stärkt die
Kaufkraft stattdessen ganz wesentlicher
Bestandteil damit unsere Bürgerinnen und
Bürger auch Geld haben um es für
Qualität für hochwertige Lebensmittel
auszugeben
Herr Stegemann sie können noch eine
Nachfrage stellen ja und zwar stelle ich
genau konkret die Nachfrage was
angesprochen wurde Thema Kostendämpfung
ich habe gestern der Fachpresse
entnommen ich habe mir liegen noch keine
konkreten Vorschläge aus dem bmwl vor
aber die Fachpresse hat gestern
verkündet das von dir Kostendämpfung
genau die Landwirtschaft von der sie
gerade gesprochen haben überhaupt nicht
profitiert also es geht hier um den vor
allen Dingen um die Bäcker und um die
Fleischer die werden entlastet aber die
Landwirtschaft wird nicht entlastet und
sie sind ja nun eben auch für die
Landwirtschaft zuständig und sie wollten
das haben sie in ihrer ersten Rede
gesagt Sie wollen Anwalt der Landwirte
sein aber jetzt höre ich das von dieser
Stelle aus überhaupt nichts kommt
Herr Minister sie können antworten danke
sehr ich bin nicht nur auch für
Landwirtschaft zu schließen ich bin der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister und der
Bundesminister für Ernährung dass nur
als technischen Hinweis und wenn es sich
mal anschauen die 180 Millionen die wir
jetzt kurzfristig auf den Weg gebracht
haben 60 Millionen von der Europäischen
Union ergänzt um 120 Millionen den
ersten Teil haben wir bereits überwiesen
wissen Sie wovons die Bauern erfahren
haben indem das Geld auf ihrem Konto war
gemeinschaftsrechtlich Antrag zuständig
da die Bäuerinnen und Bauern jetzt
gerade aber anderes zu tun haben werden
wir so machen dass wir sie anschreiben
das heißt Sie müssen nicht aktiv werden
sie werden von uns informiert das heißt
wir setzen das was sie zu Recht
einfordern dass wir in dieser
schwierigen Situation unsere Bäuerinnen
und Bauern nicht alleine lassen das
setzen wir längst um insofern ist Ihre
Frage durch Regierungshandeln erledigt
vielen Dank
gibt es weitere Fragen zum gleichen
Thema aus anderen Fraktionen
okay dann nehmen wir eine Nachfrage aus
der cdu/csu-fraktion
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister die Herausforderung für die
Landwirtschaft sind ja groß und wir
haben in ihrem ersten knappen Amtsjahr
als bundeslandwirtschaftsminister ja
auch viele Ankündigungen gehört was sie
alles anpacken wollen aber ich will sie
mal ganz konkret fragen wie viele und
welche Gesetze haben Sie denn bisher
durch den Deutschen Bundestag gebracht
sie haben Recht die Ankündigungen sind
einige das hat aber auch was damit zu
tun dass die Versäumnisse umfassend sind
und ich will die Gelegenheit mal dazu
nutzen schauen Sie sie kennen ja meine
reden von hier ich gehöre nicht zu
denjenigen die hier ständig über die 16
Jahre reden aber wenn sie so fragen dann
kriegen sie auch so eine Antwort schauen
Sie die Zukunftskommission
Landwirtschaft also auch die bäuchert
Kommission um im Fußball zu bleiben sie
sind ja auch VfB-Fan glaube ich den
Punkt den Ball auf den Elfmeterpunkt
gelegt und da war nicht mein Torwart
drin wir hatten damals keine Inflation
wir hatten damals eine andere
wirtschaftliche Lage wir hatten einen
breiten gesellschaftlichen Konsens zum
Umbau der Landwirtschaft vom
Bauernverband bis zum umweltschütze alle
waren sie bereit ihren Weg zu gehen sie
haben es nicht umgesetzt lassen Sie uns
jetzt bitte gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass
unser viel schwierigeren Bedingungen der
Inflation und erfüllt schwierigeren
Bedingungen weil natürlich auch manche
jetzt wieder versuchen auszubüchsen zu
Ursprungsposition ich lade sie wirklich
ein lassen Sie uns das gemeinsam machen
ich bin froh dass ihre Kollegen
Bundesminister in der
Agrarministerkonferenz mir den Rücken
gestärkt haben beim Thema umbaute
Tierhaltung sie wissen das ist keine
Selbstverständlichkeit da waren die
Diskussion früher viel konfrontative wie
viel Landwirtschaftsminister standen
hier schon die sich darauf berufen
konnten dass die gesamte
bäuchertkommission ich meine da sitzen
ja keine grüne drin sie wissen wer da
drin sitzt die Agrarministerkonferenz da
regiert von hier von allen
demokratischen Parteien mindestens ein
Minister dass sie sich hinter mich
gestellt haben
vielen Dank sie dürfen noch eine
Nachfrage stellen wenn Sie möchten
da hole ich gerne meine Frage also nach
vielen Ausführungen vielen Worten auch
jetzt gerade eben über die Problematik
über die Vergangenheit und so weiter
wollen wir eigentlich mal konkretes
Handeln sehen sie haben meine Frage
jetzt nicht beantwortet welche Gesetze
sind bisher von ihnen durch den
Deutschen Bundestag gebracht worden wie
viele und welche Gesetze
wir haben angefangen vom hopfengesetz
viele Verordnungen auf den Weg gebracht
jetzt gerade ist der ersten Lesung im
Kabinett der Umbau der Tierhaltung die
Ernährungsstrategie ist im Weg gebracht
wir sind ständig dran und weil vorher
das Thema Bäcker und Metzger
angesprochen wurde ich bin stolz darauf
dass wir es geschafft haben mit dem
Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz gemeinsam auch die
Interessen derjenigen von denen wir
besonders abhängig sind Bäcker
Brauereien und Metzger deren Interessen
mit auf den Weg zu bringen also gehen
Sie mal davon aus der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister kämpft Tag
und Nacht für die Interessen derer die
darauf angewiesen sind
ich habe noch eine Nachfrage aus einer
Fraktion anderen Fraktion die Frau
Künast für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen weil mein fragen da Kollege aus
der CDU so gefragt hat was hat man durch
ein Bundestag gemacht dachte ich man
könnte ja auch mal nach dem Bundesrat
Fragen ich hätte gerne noch mal eine
Vorstellung davon wie brisant war
eigentlich die Situation
bei der Umsetzung der Europäischen
Wasserrahmenrichtlinie die bei uns mit
dem Namen Düngeverordnung aufschlug
haben sie können Sie mir noch mal sagen
wie viel Jahre das lag und nicht
entschieden wurde wie teuer es hätte
werden können weil wir in der zweiten
Stufe des Vertragsverletzungsverfahren
waren und was sie dann bei der
Düngeverordnung gemacht haben
wie gesagt vielen Dank Frau Kollegen wie
gesagt ich will eigentlich gar nicht
hier den Blick zurückwerfen weil ich
glaube das hilft den Landwirt nicht viel
aber ich mache das sehr gerne
2013 aus der Zeit stammt des
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren nahezu zehn
Jahre ist das Thema nicht abgearbeitet
worden die Strafen um dies da gegangen
wäre wären 800.000 Euro pro Tag gewesen
wenn wir das alles zusammenrechnet hätte
es bis zu einer Milliarde Strafe sein
können ich will mich hier nicht mit
Dingen schmücken die ich nicht alleine
gemacht habe auch da das habe ich mit
meinem Haus auf dem Weg gebracht aber
mit Unterstützung der Agrarminister der
Länder in der sehr dankbar dafür aber es
ist noch nicht ganz rum wir müssen bis
November die umsetzungsrichtlinie in den
Ländern in trockenen Tüchern haben und
dann haben wir noch eine weitere Aufgabe
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass das
Verfahren durch eine Verdichtung des
Messstellen Netzes etc soweit optimiert
hat dass wir anschließend ein frohsam
Prinzip haben dafür setze ich mich ein
ich bin froh dass es uns gelungen keine
Strafzahlungen Deutschland hat wieder
ein anständiges Verhältnis zu Kommission
und findet dort gehören
vielen Dank wir sind immer noch zum
gleichen Thema
bei den Fragen zum gleichen Thema
gut dann lasse ich noch eine zu aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Minister die Ursprungsfrage
ging drehte sich ja um die
Nahrungsmittel um die Kosten das war ja
die Eingangsfrage für diese Runde
der Minister hat geantwortet dass
sozusagen generell für Lebensmittel die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung noch nicht in
Betracht gezogen wird ich möchte es ein
bisschen spezialisieren die Linke sie
wissen das unterstützt die Forderung die
ich auch schon aus ihrem Mund gehört
habe die Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer auf
Grundnahrungsmittel auf Null
durchzusetzen zumindest temporär sowie
diese ideeu erlaubt und da möchte ich
Sie bitten zu mir zu beantworten
sozusagen was tun Sie dafür dass diese
Forderung die auch von ihnen selbst
erhoben wurde umgesetzt wird Herr
Minister naja was war halt tut als
Minister sagt es beispielsweise und dann
schaut mal ob man dafür eine Mehrheit
hat oder nicht und ich glaube so geht es
allen hier die kabinettskolleginnen und
Kollegen von mir sind dass sie
wahrscheinlich hier und da ein Projekt
haben für das sich Unterstützung
wünschen würden durch weitere Fraktion
manchmal auch durch Mitglieder der
eigenen Fraktion oder Partei und dann
passiert es eben das ist nicht so ist
das muss ich akzeptieren das ist
Demokratie ich bin ja hier nicht
irgendwie mit einem Vetorecht
ausgestattet sondern wir müssen in einer
gemeinsamen Regierung zu gemeinsamen
Mehrheiten kommen so wie ich davon
überzeugt bin dass meine Ideen gut und
richtig sind habe ich den Verdacht das
andere das für über ihre Ideen genauso
betrachten und am Ende müssen wir
schauen wie man das vernünftig
zusammenbringen das ist in Koalition so
ich will aber auch ausdrücklich sagen
das ist uns hier im dritten
Entlastungspaket sehr gut gelungen nur
um die Punkte nochmal zu nennen die
Einmalzahlung von drei Euro
energiepreispauschale die hilft gerade
denjenigen die jetzt gerade beim
Einkaufen
die hilft jetzt gerade denjenigen die
besonders angewiesen sind beim Einkauf
denkt sie an die Ausweitung der
medishops denken Sie aber auch an die
kalte Progression die Unternehmerinnen
und unter die Landwirten Landwirte sehen
sich als Unternehmer sie profitieren
davon auch in ganz besondere Weise all
diese Dinge helfen uns in der
Landwirtschaft sie helfen aber auch den
Konsumenten und Konsumenten und damit
schließt sich ein Kreis was die Frage
des Mehrwertsteuersystems angeht ohne
dass ich jetzt vielleicht zu viel sage
und nachher Ärger bekomme das System
insgesamt glaube ich schreit danach dass
man sich mal anschaut unter logischen
Gesichtspunkten überprüft
möchten Sie noch eine Nachricht
erstellen dann würde ich jetzt in der
Liste weitergehen und die nächste
Fragestellerin ist Peggy Schierenbeck
aus der SPD-Fraktion
ja sehr geehrter Herr Minister vielen
Dank für Ihre Ausführungen
es muss für alle leichter werden sich
gesund zu ernähren die Erarbeitung einer
umfassenden ernährungstrategie kommt
genau zur richtigen Zeit ich begrüße es
daher sehr dass das BML die
förderführung übernommen hat und
relevante Steakhäuser bei der
Entwicklung der Strategie mit einbezieht
für uns als SPD-Fraktion ist die
Bekämpfung von
ernährungsarmut und der Fokus auf Kinder
und Jugendliche besonders wichtig die
Gemeinschaftsverpflegung ist da ein
zentrale Ansatzpunkt an wichtiger Hebel
den wir nutzen müssen meine Frage ist
wie ist der aktuelle Stand der
Ernährungsstrategie wann können wir mit
dem Eckpunktepapier rechnen und wie geht
der weitere Prozess vonstatten
sehr dankbar für die Frage wird es für
mich auch in Herzensanliegen ist das
Thema Ernährungsstrategie voranzubringen
als jemand der selber aus einer Familie
stammt wo man weiß was es eben heißt
wenn die Mutter oder Vater beide
berufstätig sind und du nachmittags halt
darauf angewiesen sind weil die Schule
damals keine Ganztagesschule ist wie du
schaust dass sozusagen Mittagessen
kommst insofern will ich mal hier sagen
wir sind die viertreichste oder
viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt es
muss uns möglich sein dass jedes Kind in
diesem Land in der Schule aber auch alle
ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmer in der
Fabrik alle Menschen die im Krankenhaus
sind alle die in einer Pflegeeinrichtung
sind dieses Land muss es sich leisten
können dass alle ein vollwertiges
gesundes Essen bekommt das ist unmöglich
dass wir das bis heute nicht realisiert
bekommen in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und da die Zeit davon läuft
und ihre Frage beantworten möchte wir
haben noch den startkopf gedrückt es gab
ein erste Auftaktrunde an der 150
Teilnehmer aus Verwaltung Wissenschaft
verbraucherschaft Umweltschutz
Zivilgesellschaft teilgenommen haben und
wir gehen jetzt weiter wir sind jetzt
als nächstes müssen wir das in der
Bundesregierung einbringen denn das ist
kein reiner akteursprozess sondern es
liegt mir sehr viel dran das passt zu
der Frage von vorher so fordert ein
Kabinettsbeschluss und jetzt kommt eben
als nächstes die Umsetzung in der
Bundesregierung vielleicht in aller
Kürze weil ich weiß dass sie sich dafür
interessieren es geht darum dass wir
insbesondere Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund Kinder
armutsgefährde Haushalte das für die in
den Blick nehmen auch die haben das
verdient ein gesundes vollwertiges Essen
zu bekommen die notwendigen
Informationen und den Zugang dazu
möchten Sie eine kurze Nachfrage stellen
dann frage ich gibt es aus anderen
Fraktionen der Kollege aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion eine Nachfrage
vielen Dank Frau Präsident Herr
Bundesminister sie haben gerade erwähnt
dass Ernährung sehr wichtig ist und dass
auch die Menschen gesunde Lebensmittel
zu sich nehmen dürfen können ja aktuell
erleben wir aber dass gerade bei nach
ihrer Ansicht nach vielleicht
hochwertigen Lebensmittel aus dem
Biobereich
die Absatzzahlen zurückgehen in den
Hofläden in der Direktvermarktung der
Verbraucher greift immer mehr zu Billy
Produkten in den Discounters was haben
Sie hier für Antworten darauf damit wir
diese Struktur die wir auch in den
letzten Jahren aufgebaut haben an
Hofladen Strukturen an ökologischen
vermarktungswegen von Ökolandbau über
was machen sie in ihren Haus um dieses
aufrechtzuerhalten
also erstens haben sie in Teilbereichen
recht das ist tatsächlich so dass es
eine Verlagerung gibt bei den
Konsumenten und Konsumenten ganz wichtig
das ist zum Teil etwas
unvollständig dargestellt worden der
Anteil derer die Bioprodukte kauft geht
nicht zurück sondern sie schauen wo sie
es Einkaufen sie gehen zum Discounter
sie gehen Weg zum Teil vom Bioladen sie
gehen Weg zum Teil vom Hofladen ich höre
das immer wieder es gilt übrigens auch
für die unverpackt Läden ja auch eine
ganz spannende Innovation die es in den
letzten Jahren gab was können wir tun
erstens ist es immer wichtig zu wissen
dass der Bioanteil und die biologisch
Wirtschaften gerade ihren Vorteil
ausspielen können die Abhängigkeit von
mineralischen Dünger haben sie nicht wir
merken ja gerade dass das Preisgefälle
zwischen konventionellen und Bio gerade
sich drastisch angenähert hat zum Teil
eins zu eins identisch ist weil das
erste zweite ist es braucht also hier
Informationen das dritte ist der Staat
kann über die außerhäusliche Verpflegung
in der Nachfrage einiges tun sie wissen
dass wir das 30% Ziel bis 31 haben bei
Bio da können wir was dazu beitragen
indem wir dafür sorgen dass wir in den
eigenen Kantinen zum Beispiel aber
natürlich auch dort wo wir selber
Einkäufer sind entsprechend darauf
achten also Bio regional saisonal aus
Deutschland all diese ganz Dinge wo ich
mal davon ausgehe dass wir gemeinsam
Interessen haben
Kollege auerner möchten Sie eine
Nachfrage stellen möchte nur kurzen auch
fragen was wollen sie akut auch tun für
die Einkommenssituation der
Bauernfamilien die umgestellt haben auf
Bio-Produktion die auch
in Erwartung sind sie wollen jetzt auf
ökologischen Landbau umstellen was
wollen Sie für diese Betriebe tun die
eine höhere Wertschöpfung brauchen und
nicht billig bare für den Discounter
produzieren können
völlig der Chor was das Anliegen angeht
wir haben dann ein ganzes Bündel an
Maßnahmen die den Landwirt hin und
Landwirten da helfen das eine war ja
mein Eingangsstatement Umbau der
Tierhaltung ganz wesentlicher Punkt da
ist eine bio-stufe auch mit dabei genau
aus dem Grund den Sie angesprochen haben
es gilt aber natürlich auch das
Bundesprogramm stallumbau es gilt für
das Zukunftsinvestitionsprogramm es gilt
für das Thema
Wirtschaftsdünger die Förderungen da
Unterstützung von Investitionen in
emissionsmindernde Maßnahmen bei der
Vergärung von Wirtschaftsdüngern das
gilt für das Bundesprogramm zu
Steigerung der Energieeffizienz und CO2
Einsparung der Landwirtschaft im
Gartenbau das gilt für das Thema
Aufbauhilfe 21 das gilt für das was ich
vorher angesprochen hatte mit 180
Millionen und es gilt natürlich auch für
das Klima angepasste Waldmanagement mit
der Honorierung von Ökosystemleistungen
und es gilt ganz besonders dafür dass
wir jetzt auch endlich in der Forschung
beim Ökolandbau vorangehen sie wissen
das ist ein Bereich der lange Zeit
vernachlässigt und als ein Gegenargument
gegen den Ausbau des Ökolandbaus
verwendet wurde dass die Produktivität
niedriger sei sie wissen als Praktiker
des Argument kann man umdrehen die
Wasserbindefähigkeit wie das Wasser ins
Grundgesetz geht die humusqualität oder
die Abgabe von Emissionen oder das Thema
Abhängigkeit von Futtermitteln aus
Drittstaaten vor allem aber kann man
über Forschung dazu beitragen dass wir
den Anteil bei der Produktivität nahe an
die konventionelle Wirtschaft dran
Landwirtschaft ranbringen also da sind
wir massiv unterwegs indem wir die
Mittel jetzt kräftig aufstocken
vielen Dank als nächstes habe ich eine
Nachfrage aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen Renate Künast
vielleicht können wir das Thema dass er
Auernhammer jetzt wieder auf die
Landwirtschaft verlagert hat wieder
zurück zum Thema Ernährung damit die
Menschen ziehen der naja man kann alles
immer dahin ziehen aber gut betrachten
wir es doch mal als ernährungsthema aus
der Sicht der Menschen insbesondere der
Kinder wir haben ernährungsarmut wir
haben aber auch 35 Milliarden Euro die
wegen Fehlernährung meistens zu viel vom
falschen die Krankenkassen zahlen 35
Milliarden Euro ernährungsbedingte
Erkrankung das sind Summen die für
sonstige notwendige medizinischen
Behandlungen fehlen an der Stelle das
ist eine Gerechtigkeitsfrage eine
soziale Frage und auch eine in diesem
Bereich gehört
so
ja intelligenter Zwischenruf gut sie
waren doch gegen die Dinge die ich
einführen wollte aber wir können gerne
über ihre 16 Jahre reden
so ich möchte jetzt gerne Wissens meine
Frage an den Minister was sind die
Kernpunkte einer solchen Ernährung nicht
nur der Ernährungsstrategie sondern der
Maßnahmen die kommen in der Breite in
der Gemeinschaftsverpflegung beim Thema
food waste und neue Rezepturen
auszurichten darum kommt es darauf kommt
es ja an das sind ja Punkte die jetzt
schon anstehen und vielleicht können Sie
auch sagen was die
Gemeinschaftsverpflegung in der
bundeskantine macht Frau Baas hat ja
unsere Präsidentin das Thema Ernährung
in den Kantinen hier schon an den
inneren Ausschuss gegeben also der
Bundestag bewegt sich wie bewegt sich
die Bundesregierung Herr Minister und
bitte bei der Fragestellung auch auf die
Zeit achten und aufs Thema
dann versuche ich das auch vielen Dank
also ich fange mit dem letzteren an wir
sind da dabei Gespräche zu führende Frau
Kollegen Kühnast danke dass Sie uns
daran erinnern sie haben natürlich
völlig recht wir sind da nur glaubwürdig
wenn wir das Praktizieren was wir von
anderen fordern zum fast auch die Frage
30 Prozent Bioanteil
da sind wir hinterher was die
grundsätzliche Ausrichtung angeht will
ich ihnen erstmal danken dafür dass sie
die Krankenkassen angesprochen haben
eine Stimme die wir leider viel zu wenig
hören in dem Kontext denn es hat nicht
nur was mit gesundheitlichem
Wohlbefinden zu tun dazu komme ich
gleich was die Kernziele sind und es hat
auch was damit zu tun dass man präventiv
unterwegs ist Geld spart das ist einfach
auch unter wirtschaftlichen
Gesichtspunkten sinnvoll dass wir nicht
über ernährungsbedingte Krankheiten
Ursachen schaffen die wir nachher mühsam
wieder beseitigen müssen wir abgesehen
davon was es ein Verlust an
Lebensqualität beinhaltet neben der
sozialpolitischen Sauerei das eben
manche davon besonders betroffen sind
unter dem Aspekt kann man das
Diskutieren in aller Kürze wegen der
Zeit es um einige zentrale Ziele eine
stärker zu pflanzenbetonte Ernährung die
Empfehlungen sind hier einfach ganz
eindeutig der Wissenschaft da gibt es
kein Vertun wenn man nicht postfaktisch
unterwegs ist es geht um eine weitere
Reduzierung des Konsums von zuckerfett
und Salz es geht um die Reduzierung der
Lebensmittelverschwendung auch dafür
führen wir Dinge fort aus der
Vorgängerregierung und ergänzen die
jetzt zum einige neue Maßnahmen und
schließt die um die Förderung der
Gemeinschaftsverpflegung mit einem
erhöhten Anteil dann saisonalen regional
und ökologisch klimafreundlich erzeugten
Lebensmitteln wir wollen diesen Prozess
nicht irgendwie im Elfenbeinturm bei mir
Ministerium vorantreiben soll es mir
wirklich sehr wichtig alle relevanten
Stakeholder wie man neudeutsch so schön
sagt sollen damit am Tisch sein weil am
Ende wird es nur funktionieren wenn es
gesellschaftlich angenommen wird wenn
ich da irgendwas verkünde dann bleibt
eine Verkündigung es muss
gesellschaftlich angenommen umgesetzt
werden und wir müssen das auch so machen
dass wir nicht ein wir machen für
Bildungsbürger da werde ich sehr darauf
achten es ist ein Programm für die
gesamte Gesellschaft das so aufgebaut
ist dass es auch wirklich alle in den
Blick nimmt
sie möchten keine Nachfrage mehr stellen
dann noch mal zur Ernährungsstrategie
keine Nachfrage mehr dann gehe ich
weiter in der Liste der angemeldeten
Fragensteller und als nächstes aus der
afd-fraktion Stefan proczka
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister sie haben von
Verlässlichkeit gesprochen sie haben von
Zukunft gesprochene Landwirtschaft oder
in der Ernährung das ist ja sehr
lobenswert allerdings der
Produktionsstopp der deutschen dünge
mittelhersteller skw-pisteitz
es vermutlich besonders kritisch weil
ungefähr zwei Drittel der
Düngemittelherstellung kommt aus dieser
Firma und da ist nicht nur der
düngemittelproduktionen in Europa
betroffen sondern es ist ja auch
Nebenprodukt des AdBlue und
danebenprodukt des CO2 und somit ist die
Landwirtschaft betroffen ist die
transportbetroffen ist die
Lebensmittelherstellung in dem Fall die
getränkeproduktion betroffen wie
bedenken Sie
hier einzugreifen vor allem da man heute
gehört hat dass bei uniper dass die
Firma die mittlerweile schon zum zweiten
Mal geholfen wurde einmal mit der
gasumlage und jetzt mit der verstauten
Verstaatlichung sind da ähnliche Pläne
bei Ihnen im Haus danke vielen Dank für
die Frage die Bundesregierung befindet
sich hinsichtlich der Frage der
düngemittelversorgung in engen Austausch
zum einen mit der Landwirtschaft zum
anderen mit dem Land handeln und
schließlich mit der Düngemittelindustrie
nach den derzeit unsere Regierung
vorliegende Informationen sind Engpässe
bei landwirtschaftlichen düngen mit
Versorgung für das Jahr 23 nicht
abzusehen wie sich die Verfügbarkeit
aber natürlich auch die Frage der Preise
die ist ja ganz entscheidend für
landwirtschaftliche Düngemittel im
folgenden Jahr für die heimische
Landwirtschaft entwickeln wird hängt
logischerweise nicht zuletzt vom
Fortgang des Krieges der Russlands gegen
die Ukraine ab da haben Sie
wahrscheinlich mehr Zugang über ihre
Kontakte zu Herrn Putin als das andere
Fraktion hier im Haus haben von daher
wäre das wenn Ihnen das Anliegen dass
wir unsere Landwirte nicht alleine
lassen was sich ja zu 100% Teile so
wichtig ist dann ist ein wesentlicher
Treiber vergisst man das mal nicht viele
der Fragen über die wir geredet haben
haben ihre Ursache in dem schrecklichen
verbrecherischen angriffsklick wadimir
Putins auf die Ukraine sobald der endet
gibt es eine Beruhigung an den
preismärkten sobald der endet kann die
Ukraine ihre Rolle als Lieferant wieder
einnehmen sobald der endet werden die
Preise für Düngemittel etc sinken also
insofern bitte lassen Sie uns das nicht
vergessen bei der Gelegenheit ich glaube
von hier im Namen von allen geht auch
ein Gruß an die Bäuerinnen und Bauern in
der Ukraine die ihre heimatverteidigen
und so Versorgung der Menschen beitragen
und
das Anliegen bitte auf die Zeit zu
achten ich komme zum Schluss das ist mir
natürlich als ehemaliger bierbotschafter
selber ein wichtiges Anliegen das Bier
wird nicht Schal auch da sind wir im
Gespräch Stichwort Biogas wir schauen
uns das sehr genau an wie wir denjenigen
die da betroffen sind helfen kann dass
die Produktion aufrechterhalten werden
kann
sorry für die Zeit überziehen
[Applaus]
ja Herr Minister das waren die
erwarteten lehren wortwülsen wie
putinversteher Rechtspopulist und so was
anderes ist man ja aus ihren Hause und
von innen nicht gewöhnt aber Lösungen
gab es jetzt leider wieder keine und die
der Preisanstieg bei Düngemittel war ja
schon im Oktober letzten Jahres also hat
er relativ wenig mit Ukraine Krieg zu
tun und aus dem Info Institut komme
schon im Februar vor Beginn des Krieges
das ist eine drastische Preiserhöhung
bis zu sieben Prozent im
Nahrungsmittelbedarf
Nahrungsmittelproduktion kommen wird
auch vor dem Krieg schon also kann der
Krieg eine ganz so viel damit zu tun
haben sondern hängt vielleicht eher mit
der schlechten Regierungsarbeit ihren
Hauses zusammen aber eine Frage wir
haben ja düngemittelproblem das ist uns
jetzt allen bewusst auf eine kleine
Anfrage von mir wird aktuell das
Stickstoffbedarf
zu 31% mit Wirtschaftsdünger
abgedeckt aber sie wollten die
Nutztierhaltung reduzieren also wie
decken wir dann die Probleme ab mit
Dünger wenn Sie die Tierhaltung
reduzieren wollen wir aber auf
Wirtschaftsdünger angewiesen sind wo nur
dazu jetzt das Stickstoffdünger
Produktion eingestellt wird danke schön
also wenn man der weltweiten zunehmend
angespannten versorgungssituationen was
Düngemittel angeht begegnen will dann
ist doch der gerade zu zwingende
wichtigste Ansatz dass wir den Einsatz
von Energien intensiven mineralischem
Stickstoffdünger reduzieren und immer da
womöglich durch alternative idealerweise
auch ökologisch
vorzugsvorzugswürdigere Maßnahmen
ersetzen sie haben einen Punkt
angesprochen das ist das Thema
Wirtschaftsdünger ich meine da haben wir
ein dramatischen Wandel viele Bäuerinnen
und Bauern hatten früher Schwierigkeiten
das Zeug loszuwerden das hat sie viel
Geld gekostet mittlerweile kriegen sie
Geld dafür da hat sich einiges geändert
insgesamt geht es uns darum die
Abhängigkeit von fossilen Energieträgern
auch bei uns in unserem Ressort zu
beenden wir haben ja beim Biogas jetzt
schon mal einiges möglich gemacht das
wird uns helfen auch das übrigens eine
gute Einnahmequelle für unsere
Bäuerinnen und Bauern auch was den
Einsatz von Gülle angeht und natürlich
geht es auch darum dass wir überall da
wirklich versuchen durch Digitalisierung
durch technischen Fortschritt die
Notwendigkeit zum Einsatz von
Stickstoffdünger reduzieren da haben
unsere Bauern durch die wirtschaftliche
Not schon einiges an Einsparungen
bewerkstelligt bei der Gelegenheit
übrigens kann man denen auch dafür
danken dass die unter diesen
schwierigsten Bedingungen versuchen den
Betrieb aufrecht zu halten es wirklich
eine riesen Leistung
wir sind beim Thema
düngemittelversorgung Industrie ich sehe
weitere nachfragen
bevor ich sie dran nehme nehme ich erst
den Kollegen aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
für eine Nachfrage zum Thema
düngemittelversorgung Industrie vielen
Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr Minister SKW
priesteritz sagt dass die gasumlage 30
Millionen Zusatzkosten pro Monat
bedeutet Produktion steht still mit
allen Folgen
adblueversorgung aber eben auch die
Auswirkungen auf die
düngemittelproduktion jetzt haben sie ja
sicher heute im Kabinett auch über
dieses Thema der gasumlage diskutiert
mich würde interessieren wie sie sich
eingebracht haben in dieser Debatte als
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister waren sie
vielleicht auch in der einen Runde dabei
woher Habeck Medienberichten zufolge ja
die gasumlage an für sich in Frage
gestellt hat wie ist ihre Position als
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister zu
gasumlage ich habe nicht eingebracht im
Kabinett wo es keine Kabinettssitzung
gab die letzte Kabinettssitzung fand
letzte Woche statt wir sind eng im
Gespräch mit dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister raus und das
Haus des Wirtschaftsministers aber auch
wir persönlich über die Frage wie wir
dazu beitragen können dass der
notwendige Bedarf auch was die
energiesicherung angeht der
Lebensmittelwirtschaft der
düngerindustrie von allen gesichert
werden kann es kann glaube ich keine
zwei Meinungen darüber geben dass das
gerade zu Existenz sicher ist und
insofern ist bei der Priorisierung keine
zwei Meinungen darüber gibt dass die
ganz vorne sind was die Frage angeht ob
man darüber hinausgehend Maßnahmen
trifft es gab ja auch die Forderungen
Dünger Vorrat zu machen ich versuche mir
das gerade praktisch vorzustellen wie
das hätte aussehen soll der Staat greift
ein den marktschaften Dünger Vorrat
eine Verknappung dadurch logischerweise
in Anstieg der Preise mit dramatischen
Konsequenzen also da bin ich doch immer
noch ein Fan des Marktes und finde wir
müssen schauen wie wir den Markt helfen
dass er funktioniert aber ich glaube
nicht dass der Staat da der bessere
Ratgeber ist wenn er jetzt ein Dünger
Vorrat schafft das würde nur zu einer
künstlichen Verteuerung der Preise
führen es wäre glaube ich keine gute
Idee möchten Sie eine Nachfrage stellen
dann habe ich jetzt den Kollegen Kraft
aus der afd-fraktion
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin in den
vergangenen Sitzungswoche der
haushaltswoche gab es eine Sondersitzung
des Ausschusses für Energie und Klima
und ihr Partei und Kabinettskollege der
Mitte Kanzler Harbeck hat dort sinngemäß
es war nicht öffentliche Sitzung
sinngemäß gesagt er sieht für die
erdgasverabend Industrie insbesondere
den ammoniakprozess keine Dauer für
Zukunft im Standort Deutschlands nun ist
Ammoniak ein Grundstoff für die
düngemittelproduktion und die Frage ist
wie Sie mit Ihrem Ressort damit umgehen
dass ihr Kollege für die
grundstoffversorgung mit Ammoniak in
Deutschland keine Zukunft sieht weil
Energiepreise weiter hoch bleiben werden
wie ist die Äußerung nicht bekannt
deshalb kann ich nichts dazu sagen aber
mit dem Kollegen Habeck sind wir eng im
Gespräch und der hat es nun mehrfach zum
Ausdruck gebracht
die hat mehrfach zum Ausdruck gebracht
das völlig klar ist dass alles was mit
ernährungssicherungen zu tun hat
systemrelevant ist ich meine allein dass
sie die Frage stellen zeigt ja dass sie
da irgendwie nicht ganz richtig
gewickelt sind die Ernährungssicherung
dieses Landes ist systemrelevant und das
ist glaube ich eine Meinung selbst wenn
hier diese Regierung nicht mehr regieren
würde und die Union regieren würde oder
wer auch immer regieren würde wird die
in Landwirtschaftsminister von welcher
Partei auch immer immer sagen
Ernährungssicherung ist systemrelevant
das hat immer oberste Priorität zu sein
das ist ja wohl sowas von klar ich bin
froh dass es der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister auch so sieht
und übrigens hatten wir auch ein
Gespräch mit Klaus Müller auf meine
Veranlassung hin mit den mit der
Lebensmittelindustrie das haben wir sehr
früh gemacht um da eben auch den Sorgen
zu begegnen ich bin sehr dankbar will
auch das an der Stelle sagen dass die
Lebensmittelindustrie ihren Beitrag dazu
leistet zu sparen das keine
selbstverständ das sind zum Teil
Prozesse die alles andere als ohne sind
dass sie eben ihren Beitrag dazu leisten
dass wir insgesamt gut durch den Winter
kommen auch da kann man mal Dinge nicht
danke sagen dass die
Lebensmittelindustrie jetzt bereits
ihren Beitrag leistet zum Energiesparen
und versucht diese Krise zu nutzen dass
wir danach stärker dastehen
wir können auch eine kurze Nachfrage
stellen ja vielen Dank Herr Minister
wunderbar dass du dieses systemrelevant
der Ernährungssituation in Deutschland
aufzeigen aber ich möchte mal
feststellen die Systemrelevanz der
Ernährung hängt an den Düngemittel die
Düngemittel hängen an der
ammoniakproduktion die Produktion hängt
an Energieversorgung und wie wir von
ihrem Kollegen und Vizekanzler wissen
ist die Energieversorgung bei uns ein
Glücksspiel das von einem guten Winter
abhängt der uns vielleicht eine Chance
gibt dass wir da gut durchkommen wie
systemrelevant halten Sie die Hoffnung
auf gutes Wetter im kommenden Winter aus
der folglich die amina-produktion aus
der erfolgreiche düngemittelproduktion
und aus der folglich die Produktion von
Lebensmittel im nötigen Umfang für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland abhängt wie
systemrelevant ist die Hoffnung auf
gutes Wetter das hat er nicht gesagt das
ist einfach nicht zutreffen deshalb
korrigiere ich das bei der Gelegenheit
diese Äußerung ist falschen sie sollte
auch nicht öffentlich verbreitet werden
sondern im Gegenteil der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister auch da kann
man danke sagen die Opposition dann
vielleicht unterm Tisch wir sind bei
über 90 Prozent was die gefühlten
Speicher angeht ich gestehe ich
das hätte ich nicht für möglich gehalten
als ich die ersten Informationen über
den Zustand der Speicher erfahren habe
das ist eine gute Nachricht für unser
Land parteiübergreifend dass wir bei
über 90 Prozent sind wir sind was
lng-terminals angeht wir sind was die
Verfahrensbeschleunigung angeht wir sind
was den Ausbau dort erneuerbaren Energie
ein Energien angeht übrigens auch unter
Einschluss von Beschlüssen sie kennen
die die auch hier und da uns wehtun
Stichwort wie wir das im Verhältnis
setzen zum Naturschutz bei
verfahrensbeschleunigungen nicht eins
sage ich Ihnen auch wenn jeder immer
sagt was gerade nicht geht dann wird es
nicht funktionieren wir brauchen eine
sichere funktionierende
Energieversorgung in der viertgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt die bezahlbar
ist und zu den Preisen ratlichen gerne
mal ein Blick in die europäischen
Nachbarländer die eher Energieform
nutzen die sie glaube ich eher
bevorzugen vergleichen Sie das mal da
werden Sie sehen dass wir auf einem
guten Weg sind in Deutschland und wir
werden durch diesen Winter dank unserer
Bevölkerung dank unserer großartigen
Wirtschaft gemeinsam solidarisch kommen
es wird keinen erfolgreichen
Erpressungsversuch Putins gegenüber
Deutschland geben wir werden dafür
sorgen unterstützt durch die
demokratische Opposition und Sie werden
sich ärgern wie man ja hören konnte bei
nicht abgestellten Mikrofon
ich
möchte noch mal an die Zeit erinnern
dass sich alle daran halten sonst kommen
wir mit den Fragen nicht durch nicht
möchte auch noch mal auf das Thema
kommen die Ursprungsfrage war
düngemittelversorgung und der Teil der
Industrie dazu und ich habe jetzt noch
eine Nachfrage von dem Kollegen Karl Bär
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
vielen Dank für die Ausführungen ich
selbst finde es sehr bedenklich dass wir
für ein Teil der Lebensmittelversorgung
darauf angewiesen sind dass die
konventionelle Landwirtschaft
ausreichend Düngemittel aus Fabriken
bekommt die angewiesen sind auf fossile
Energieträger die wir von weit her
importieren müssen was jetzt
offensichtliche Probleme schafft dass
wir uns abhängig gemacht haben von
Russland und Herrn Putin wie kommen wir
dazu von diesen Abhängigkeiten
runterzukommen die er bestehen
das betrifft ist natürlich vor allem
andere Ressource aber in aller Kürze da
ich auch Mitglieder Bundesregierung bin
ist der wesentlichste Bestandteil
sicherlich dass wir so schnell wie
möglich schauen dass wir die
Abhängigkeit von fossilen Energieträgern
reduzieren
da wo fossile Energieträger herkommt
schauen wir uns mal die Regierungsform
an da gibt es wenig Demokratien es sind
fast alles autoritäre
gesellschaftschaften bis zu Diktaturen
insofern haben wir alle miteinander
Interesse daran dass es im Turbogang
vorangeht und inzwischenruf habe ich
wohl gehört aber da sollten Sie sich
über die ärgern die uns in diese Lage
gebracht haben dass wir jetzt
entscheiden müssen wo wir die Energie
herholen um dafür zu sorgen dass wir
sicher durch diesen Winter kommen dazu
gehört der Ausbau der Netze auch das
haben wir streiflich vernachlässigt dazu
gehört eine massive endbürokratisierung
das bringen wir gerade voran dazu gehört
natürlich auch dass mein Sektor sein
Beitrag dazu leisten indem wir die
Abhängigkeit von mineralischen Dünger
reduzieren indem wir beispielsweise
Programme auflegen das haben wir schauen
dass diese Programme auch abgerufen
werden das machen wir jetzt besser wie
wir auch da dafür sorgen können das
landwirtschaftliche Betriebe auf fossile
Energieträger weniger angewiesen sind
die Aufgabe ist eine nationale das
betrifft kommunenländerbund gemeinsam
und natürlich auch die Europäische Union
und dass die gesamte Regierung betrifft
betrifft es auch mein Haus auch mein
Haus muss seinen Beitrag dazu leisten
dass die Abhängigkeit von fossilen
Energieträgern so schnell wie möglich
untergeht das tun wir
möchten Sie eine Nachfrage stellen nein
danke
gibt es weitere zu dem Thema
Düngemittelindustrie sonst würde ich
nämlich in der Liste gerne weiter
fortfahren
kurz zum Thema düngemittelversorgung
logisch ich habe mich ja schon ziemlich
lange gemeldet nachdem die Aussage von
Herrn Özdemir kam die sinngemäß lautete
die Bundesregierung befürchtet für das
Jahr 2023 keinen Mangel in den
Düngemittel fahren sorgung ich hoffe ich
habe das richtig so vernommen und da
habe ich mich daran erinnert dass in
diesem Jahr schon die dünge mit Preise
sich ungefähr für fünftacht haben was ja
wohl auf eine absoluten Mangel in diesem
Jahr schon hinweist sonst würde dir die
Preise nicht explodieren sie haben
vielleicht Grundwissen was Angebot und
Nachfrage angeht unterstelle ich jetzt
mal vielleicht sind sie da ein bisschen
pfiffiger als der Kollege Harbeck also
wenn wir keine mangelage hätten dann
würde in diesem Jahr während die Preise
schon nicht explodiert ich sag mal meine
Frage wie definieren Sie denn eine
mangelage an Düngemitteln dass ich gar
keine mehr Dünger will leisten kann oder
nur die oder die die die viel Geld haben
und wir auch schön wenn Sie die Frage
jetzt versuch mal zu beantworten ohne
direkt persönlich zu werden ohne
Plattitüden rauszublasen und ohne die
AFD zu beleidigen sie meinen so wie Sie
es gerade am Anfang Ihre Frage gemacht
haben ne das habe ich ein bisschen das
habe ich ein bisschen anders gelernt in
meiner Schule aber ich bin auch nicht in
Bulgarien auf die Schule gegangen aber
zu Ihrer Frage
Bulgarien habe ich gesagt wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt auf die Antwort
des Ministers zum Thema ich habe bewusst
gesagt ich zitiere es noch mal den Satz
habe ich mir extra aufgeschrieben
mögliche Engpässe was die Preise angeht
habe ich gesagt was die Menge angeht ist
es gegenwärtig zu früh um was drüber zu
sagen wir wissen beispielsweise auch
beim Weizen das ist neben der
verfügbaren Menge auch noch mal eine
preisspekulation gibt über volatile
Märkte hier ist es ein ähnlicher Weise
so das heißt es gibt einen Zusammenhang
aber es ist nicht zwingend so dass die
Menge alleine den Preis bestimmt weil
wir es eben hier auch mit volatin
Märkten zu tun haben was wir also
beitragen können ist ich wiederhole es
noch mal so schnell wie möglich den
Krieg beenden was wir beitragen können
ist die Abhängigkeit von fossilen
Energieträgern reduzieren was wir
beitragen können ist da wo möglich für
ersatzsorten das machen wir
beispielsweise mit Biogas das hilft
heute bereits vielen wir haben es beim
Getränkehandel schauen wir uns das sehr
genau an alle die die auf Kohlensäure
angewiesen sind mit denen sind wir im
Gespräch wie können wir dazu beitragen
das Abhängigkeit reduziert werden das
Ziel ist dass wir möglichst niemand
dabei verlieren und auf der Strecke
lassen
möchten Sie eine Nachfrage stellen
[Applaus]
eine reine Verständnisfrage jetzt haben
sie gesagt das mit der mangelage dass
die nicht eintreten so im nächsten Jahr
das wäre hätte ich falsch verstanden es
wäre eine mangelage die sich an den
Preisen orientiert das habe ich jetzt
wieder nicht verstanden was hat was
haben die die Preise mit einer Mangel
Lage zu tun Herr Bundesminister Özdemir
ich kann ihn auch nicht
Interpretationshilfe noch nachliefern
nach den derzeit uns vorliegenden
Informationen sind Engpässe bei
landwirtschaftlichen Düngemittel
Versorgung für 23 gegenwärtig nicht
abzusehen ich sage aber auch wie sich
die Verfügbarkeit und die Preise für
landwirtschaftliche Düngemittel im
kommenden Jahr für unsere heimische
Landwirtschaft entwickeln werden das
hängt von Faktoren ab die ich jetzt
glaube ich schon mehrfach genannt habe
darunter dem Krieg in der Ukraine man
kann ja sehen wenn man den 28 als
Maßstab nimmt der vorde nach dann sehen
sie ja welchen Einfluss des hatte
insofern sind es Faktoren auf die der
Landwirtschaftsminister nur bedingt
Einfluss hat worauf der
Landwirtschaftsminister Einfluss das
versuchte zu machen indem er hilft die
Abhängigkeit von fossilen Energieträgern
zu reduzieren man kann es ja umdrehen es
gibt diesen schönen Spruch den kennen
vielleicht manche dass man keine Krise
ungenutzt an sich vorbeigehen lassen
sollte wir sollten diese Krise die uns
jetzt noch mal daran erinnert hat welche
Abhängigkeit wir haben nutzen um uns
möglichst resilient aufzustellen
vielen Dank die nächste Frage ich gehe
jetzt weiter in der Rangfolge
in die FDP-Fraktion und die nächste
Frage stellt Carina Konrad
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister auch wenn das eben hier anders
durchgeklungen ist Ernährungssicherheit
und Nachhaltigkeit die gehören zusammen
und darüber sind wir uns ja eigentlich
da haben wir uns ja auch als
Koalitionspartner zu verständigt und der
schreckliche Krieg zeigt ja oder hat uns
vor Augen geführt auf eine dramatische
Art und Weise was ich persönlich 2022
auch nicht mehr für möglich gehalten
hätte nämlich das Hunger auf dieser Welt
wieder als Waffe eingesetzt wird und wir
merken das ja auch bei uns dass die
Inflation an der Supermarktkasse
tatsächlich auch dazu führt dass die
Menschen überlegen für was sie ihren
Euro noch ausgeben können sprich
Ernährungssicherheit und Nachhaltigkeit
das gehört zusammen und wenn es keine
Ernährungssicherheit gibt Gerät die
Nachhaltigkeit auch ein Stück weit unter
die Räder und jetzt haben wir die
Landwirtschaft die Winzer sind in heller
Aufruhr in vielen Regionen Deutschlands
weil die eu-kommissionen Vorschlag
gemacht hat der aus unserer Sicht für
ein Land das schon sehr weit vorgegangen
ist auch gerade in punkto Nachhaltigkeit
nach vorne gegangen ist der das der zu
großen Problem führt in vielen vielen
Regionen Deutschlands sollen Pflanzen
Lebensmittel in sensiblen Gebieten nicht
mehr eingesetzt werden ich habe mich
sehr gefreut Herr Minister dass sie
diese Schieflage der Kommission hier
auch sehr klar benannt haben und deshalb
möchte ich an dieser Stelle auch mal
fragen was tun wir jetzt weiterhin wie
bringen wir uns ein dass die Europäische
Kommission hier auch diese Schieflage
korrigiert
ja vielen Dank für die Frage erst mal
vor der Klammer der Einsatz von
Pflanzenschutzmitteln muss gesenkt
werden da gibt es glaube ich kein Vertun
wenn wir öffentliche Güter wie
Artenvielfalt und Wassergüte schützen
wollen das ist Teil der farmte
volksstrategie zu der sich die
Vorgängerregierung ja verpflichtet hatte
sich daran zu beteiligen das stellt auch
die Bundesregierung stellt mein Haus
nicht in Zweifel das grundsätzliche
ansehen trennen teilen wir aber sie
haben das angesprochen ich sehe
Verbesserungsbedarf in dem was dagegen
werde ich auf dem Tisch liegt um das
auch klar zu sagen es handelt sich hier
weil das auch falsch transportiert wird
um ein Vorschlag um einen Entwurf es ist
kein geltendes Recht das ist die
verhandlungslogik in Brüssel für die
dieses Wissen ich sehe ein paar
Baustellen mit denen wir uns
beschäftigen zum einen man muss sich die
flächenkulisse sehr genau anschauen ich
glaube die Definition sogenannter
sensibler Gebiete
die entspricht europaweit ist die nicht
identisch wir haben den Deutschland
bestimmte gebietsdefinitionen dies
anderswo einfach so nicht gibt das kann
nicht nur zu unserem Nachteil erreichen
zweitens man muss genau schauen was ist
bereits an erzielten
Reduzierungen erreicht worden welches
Referenz ja nehmen wir da werde ich sehr
genau darauf hinschauen dass wir da
aufpasst dass nicht diejenigen die schon
vorangegangen sind dass es denen zum
Nachteil gereicht und dritter Punkt der
uns zum Bäuerinnen und Bauern sehr
wichtig ist das ganze muss bitte so
gestaltet werden dass es keine
übermäßige Bürokratie gibt
sie möchten gerne Nachfrage stellen
gerne sie haben es gerade richtig gesagt
die deutsche Landwirtschaft ist
Vorreiter in vielen Gebieten sie ist
vorgegangen bei Digitalisierung sie ist
vorgegangen bei ganz vielen
Nachhaltigkeitsthemen und deshalb ist es
gut dass das eine zum Nachteil werden
soll darauf wir müssen wir uns einsetzen
wie können wir es denn schaffen das
EU-weite Regeln auch viel stärker
harmonisiert werden in Zukunft das wäre
meine Nachfrage kurz und bündig mal an
der Stelle zur Abwechslung heute
ja da gibt es ja ein paar Dinge die man
sich sehr genau anschauen könnte die
Länder haben dazu ja zum Teil unter
heftigsten kämpfen sie kennen das
beispielsweise in Baden-Württemberg mit
mit Volksabstimmungen und mit
moderierten Prozessen das schauen wir
uns sehr genau an ich finde zum Beispiel
das sehr spannend so ein moderierter
Prozess dass man da nicht eben mit
vollendeten Tatsachen arbeitet das
zweite ist ich war ja auf dem
informellen Rad in Prag und habe dort
auch die Gelegenheit genutzt mit dem
Kommissar zu sprechen die Bedenken die
ich jetzt gerade geäußert habe schon mal
zum Ausdruck zu bringen aber ich habe
auch das Gespräch gesucht mit anderen
Mitgliedstaaten und zum Teil bei den
Ländern die ein ähnliches Phänomen haben
wie sie es besprochen haben die schon
weitergegangen sind gibt es ähnliche
Sorgen ähnliche Fragezeichen also wir
vernetzen uns da und versuchen das
gemeinsam voranzubringen mit dem Ziel
dass die Grundrichtung bleibt aber wir
in der Umsetzung aufpassen dass der
Schuss nicht nach hinten losgeht
war das eine Nachfrage dazu dann
bitteschön
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich bleibe
beim Thema Ernährungssicherheit und
möchte da einen speziellen Aspekt der
ernährungsnotfallvorsorge ansprechen und
zwar lagern wir ja Getreide Weizen ein
in unseren Lebensmittel notfallrad und
ich möchte sie Herr Bundesminister
fragen wie sie dazu stehen dass man
Teile dieser Notreserve durch
Fertigprodukte ersetzt die ebenfalls die
zehn Jahre Lagerdauer einhalten können
und in der Anwendung im Katastrophenfall
oder im zivilschutzfall deutlich
leichter sind
das ist eine sehr komplizierte Frage und
das sind der vorgegebene Zeit ich
versuche es trotzdem einigermaßen kurz
zu machen zunächst mal vielleicht vor
der Klammer weil es da auch
Missverständnisse gibt der staatlicher
Ernährungs notfalls Sorge liegt nicht
Ansatz zugrunde dass wir eine
Vollversorgung für die Bevölkerung
gewährleisten können sondern es geht
allenfalls zum staatliche Notreserven
den zusätzlichen Beitrag leisten das
Wichtigste das ist das worüber wir
vorher zum Teil kontrovers gesprochen
haben ist und bleibt die
privatwirtschaftliche
lebensmittelschöpfungskette solange wie
es nur irgendwie geht funktionsfähig zu
halten also die versorgende Bevölkerung
mit Lebensmitteln erfolgt in Deutschland
erstmal über den Markt durch Unternehmen
nicht durch den Staat das lassen wir
bitteschön auch so der Staat hilft
Additiv und wir machen das eben durch
Produkte wie Erbsen wie Reis und Weizen
die langjährig eingelagert werden können
bis zu zehn Jahre die man dann
anschließend auch den Markt wieder
zugänglich macht das ist die positive
gegenwärtig haben
sie hatten auch noch eine Nachfrage dazu
dann sind sie jetzt dran und dann komme
ich noch wieder zur FDP zurück und dann
sind die Nachfragen zu diesem Punkt
glaube ich erstmal erschöpft
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich möchte
zurück zum Thema zum pflanzschutz kommen
was da eigentliche Grund dieser Frage
war es gibt jetzt diesen Vorschlag der
EU-Kommission namentlich von Herrn
Timmermanns
sehr sehr viele pflanzschutzmittel nicht
mehr auf Flächen auszubringen es gibt
Berechnungen von 3,5 Millionen Hektar
Ackerfläche in Deutschland die nicht
mehr mit pflanzschutzmittel behandelt
werden dürfen was sagen sie den
Bauernfamilien den Weinbaubetrieben die
diesen Flecken haben welche Flächen sind
es überhaupt und wie steht das
in ihrem Parteiprogramm steht irgendwas
drin von erheblicher Reduzierung von
pflanzenschutzmitteleinsatz ist jetzt
meine Formulierung sie haben eine andere
drin stehen wie wollen Sie das in ihrer
Koalition dann auflösen wir müssen doch
diese pflanzschutzmittel auf dem Flächen
gerade im Weinbau auch einsetzen dürfen
ich habe es ja gerade gesagt wir schauen
uns die flächenkulisse sehr genau an
also es gibt bestimmte Definitionen
beispielsweise Landschaftsschutzgebiete
das Instrument kennen nicht alle Länder
wir schauen uns zweitens an wie wird es
umgesetzt was den bürokratischen Aufwand
angeht und wir schauen uns drittens
genau an was ist das Referenzjahr was
wird an Vorleistungen einberechnet gehen
Sie mal davon aus der bundesagenminister
ist da ein Film und und setzt sich dafür
ein dass eine ausgewogene Lösung
gefunden wird die auf der einen Seite
das will ich auch noch mal ausdrücklich
sagen die berechtigten Interessen ich
meine wir machen das ja nicht aus Jux
und Tollerei wir machen das weil wir ein
dramatischen Artenschwund haben wir
machen das weil wir eine dramatische
Situation haben gegen die wir was machen
müssen das ganze müssen wir aber so
machen das habe ich vorher auch gesagt
dass wir dabei nicht übers Ziel
hinausschießen ich habe die Position
Brüssel so wahrgenommen wie bei
Tarifverhandlungen dass man erstmal
ins maximum fordert um dann zu schauen
dass man auch einiges davon umsetzt wir
in der Praxis uns das an dass es eben
auch für Deutschland funktioniert das
muss einfach in allen Mitgliedsländern
funktionieren und das sind einige
Fragezeichen die wir haben die habe ich
ja gerade genannt die muss ich nicht
wiederholen
nee noch eine Nachfrage dürfen sie nicht
stellen weil sie waren ja nicht der
ursprüngliche Frage
okay ich höre gerade die Präsidentin
hatte heute ihren großzügigen Tag dann
würde ich dem nicht nachstehen
[Gelächter]
und lasse die Nachfrage noch zu dann
kommt Herr Hocker dann kommt Herr
Stadler und dann gucken wir mal dass wir
auch wenigstens noch eine ich habe sie
gesehen dann dass sie wenigstens eine
Runde durchziehen durch die Fraktion das
muss möglich sein und der ist es wie
möchte auch noch einmal fragen und das
soll auch möglich sein bitte schön
vielen Dank für die Großzügigkeit des
Präsidiums an diesen heutigen Tag
Bundesminister möchte konkret nachfragen
diese Reduzierung von pflanzschutzmittel
wie wirkt sich das auf Bauernfamilien
aus die ihren gesamten
landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb zum
Beispiel in einen FFH-Gebiet haben in
einer Natura 2000 Gebiet haben denen
damals gesagt worden ist für eure
Betriebe endet nichts ändert sich nichts
bei dieser gebietskulissenausweisung wie
welche Antworten haben Sie für diese
Bauernfamilien die ihre komplette
Betriebsstätte in solchen Gebieten haben
und jetzt vom Brüssel aus hören sie
dürfen zukünftig keine
pflanzschutzmittel mehr einsetzen bitte
konkret sein ich sage es einfach
nochmals in der Hoffnung dass sie es
auch richtig weitertragen weil das
glaube ich für das gesellschaftliche
Klima ganz entscheidendes bei uns im
Land es handelt sich hier um einen
Vorschlag einen Entwurf der Kommission
und wer das europäische Prozedere kennt
weiß das muss
durch uns durch das muss in den
nationalen Ländern noch debattiert
werden und gehen Sie mal davon aus dass
was ich jetzt hier gerade in Fragen
beantworte das wird genauso in einigen
anderen Mitgliedstaaten nehmen Sie zum
Beispiel dänemark ist ein Land auf das
wir schauen weil es da mutig
vorangegangen ist beim Thema
pestizidabbau die haben auch viele
Fragen weil sie sagen wir wollen jetzt
nicht als Landes vorangegangen ist dass
es uns zum Nachteil gereicht also wenn
genau diese Punkte eingebracht ich will
aber ihre Frage auch nochmal als
Gelegenheit nutzen damit der jetzt auch
nicht eine falsche Tonlage reinkommt
gerade das Beispiel Dänemark zeigt ganz
erstaunlich
und das ist übrigens jetzt nicht einfach
von mir sondern durch zahlreiche
wissenschaftliche Studien belegt dass
man den Einsatz von Pestiziden
nennenswert reduzieren kann ohne dass
die Ernten drunter leiden müssen
ähnliche Beispiele gibt es auch von
anderen Ländern auch der schauen wir uns
sehr genau an ich glaube auch da geht
technisch sehr viel mittlerweile über
Precision Farming und so weiter all die
ganzen Dinge die wir ebenfalls fördern
also ich bitte um Verständnis dafür dass
sich die Verhandlungsposition mit
Brüssel jetzt nicht hier austrage ich
habe ja meine leitline Leitplanken
genannt unter diesen Prämissen verhandle
ich das mache ich übrigens auch im
Gespräch mit den Bauernorganisationen
und die Punkte die ich da genannt habe
decken sich ungefähr mit den Punkten die
dort auch gewünscht werden
so jetzt sage ich Ihnen mal welche
Reihenfolge ich jetzt hier vorsehe damit
wir auf jeden Fall eine Runde durch die
Fraktion erreichen können und dann ist
die Nachfragemöglichkeit gegebenenfalls
auch etwas geringer jetzt kommt Herr
Hocker dran dann Herr Straubinger dann
Herr Hoffmann und dann kommt Herr
Seidler dran
erklärte frau Präsidentin verehrte Herr
Minister darf ich Ihre Antwort auf die
vorher gegangene Frage so werden dass
sie meine Auffassung teilen das in
Zeiten von globaler Nahrungsmittel
Knappheit in Zeiten von Inflation in
Zeiten ist auch das Klimawandels weil
andere Formen der Unkrautbekämpfung sind
deutlich CO2 intensiver als mit
Pflanzenschutz dabei zu gehen dass die
Vorschläge von Herrn Timmermanns
vollständig aus der Zeit gefallen sind
und vor allem dass Sie sich dafür
verwenden werden als Teil der
Bundesregierung dass sie so in
Deutschland nicht zur Anwendung kommen
werden
nein da hätten sie mich glaube ich
überinterpretiert ich mache hier auch
kein Thema manspashing sondern Herr
Timmermanns bringt ein berechtigtes
Anliegen was Bestäuber angeht was das
Thema Vielfalt angeht auf dem Weg aber
die Umsetzung passt so nicht weil sie
für Deutschland ein paar Parameter
übersieht die habe ich genannt dazu
stehe ich und ich würde auch nicht dazu
raten dass wir die eine Krise gegen die
andere ausspielen wir müssen alle Krisen
gleichermaßen angehen ich weiß dass das
ein wahnsinnige Herausforderung ist dass
es sich hier und da wir teilen da der
die Einschätzung anhört wie wie ein Berg
den man gar nicht abgetragen bekommt
aber billiger ist es nicht zu haben die
Zeit in der wir leben fordert von uns
dass wir für die Ernährungssicherung
beitragen gleichzeitig dafür sorgen dass
die biodiversitätskrise angegangen wird
und gleichzeitig die Klimakrise bekämpft
wird mein Ratschlag wäre dass wir da
auch kein konfrontativen Stil führen
wozu uns das führt das haben wir bei
nitrat-richtlinien der Vergangenheit
gesehen das Ergebnis war ganz gut Fall
für Deutschland vertrauen sie da auf
mein Stil mein Stil ist nicht dass man
mit dem Hintern voraus den
Gesprächspartnern im Regelfall begegnet
sondern mit ausgestreckter Hand so führe
ich das Gespräch in Brüssel und bis
jetzt haben wir ja gute Sachen erreicht
denken Sie an blöd sieben blöds 8 das
war ja auch ein schmerzhafter Kompromiss
auch für mich ich versuche die Dinge
ausgewogen zu machen mit Maß und Mitte
aber mit Maß und Mitte heißt auch dass
man den Thema meines jetzt hier nicht
irgendwie in den Senkel stellt
[Applaus]
Herr Bundesminister sie haben vorhin so
viel auf die Ernährung Sicherheit auch
abgestellt in ihren Antworten und es ist
auch verbunden mit dem Einsatz von
Pflanzenschutzmittel den dies tragen ja
dazu bei dass der Tragsicherheit auch
mitgegeben ist beziehungsweise auch
minimal bodenbewirtschaftungen auch also
möglich sind das geht dann nicht ohne
Pflanzenschutzmittel jetzt haben wir ja
das glyphosat-verbot das er dazu
beiträgt dass letztendlich wesentlich
mehr umgedreht werden muss aber mir geht
es um eine andere Situation nämlich wäre
es nicht besser und klüger auch wieder
neue Wirkstoffe schneller zuzulassen die
müssen dich effektiver vielleicht sind
aber derzeit in der Zulassungspraxis in
Deutschland beim UBA liegen oder weil
sich das
Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium in
Umweltministerium nicht einigen kann und
damit neu Wirkstoffe nicht zum Einsatz
kommen die vielleicht weniger belastend
sind in der Ausbringung für die Natur
vielleicht sagen Sie was dazu was sie
meinen meinen Sie jetzt die neue
Gentechnik oder was ein
Pflanzenschutzmittel
angesprochen haben dazu sagen dazu gibt
es eine klare koalitionsposition wir
haben das eine Koalitionsvereinbarung
stehen das ab 1 Januar 24 kein Glyphosat
mehr angewendet werden soll wir stehen
auch jede Verlängerung auf europäische
Ebene da sehr kritisch gegenüber ob es
eine qualifizierte Mehrheit für die
Wiederzulassung von Glyphosat geben wird
oder nicht ich kann es ihnen schlicht
nicht sagen es gab mal ein Fenster das
kennen sie das ist leider nicht genutzt
worden da war Deutschland
ausschlaggebend ich führe viele
Gespräche und werde auch noch mal die
Auswirkung von Glyphosat auf die
Biodiversität auch ins Gespräch kriegen
aber ich will die Gelegenheit hier auch
nutzen und nochmal deutlich zu machen
ob ein vollständiges nationales
Anwendungsverbot des über die bisherigen
Beschränkungen in der Pflanzenschutz
anwendungsverordnung hinausgeht in
Einklang mit gemeinschaftlichen Vorgaben
steht das kann ich nicht sagen das
prüfen wir gerade umfassend wir werden
dazu auch die Urteile aus zu Österreich
und zu Luxemburg ich sag aber auch hier
als ihr bundeslandwirtschaft
Landwirtschaftsminister ich werde alle
Möglichkeiten prüfen um den
Koalitionsvertrag hier umzusetzen und
ich sage jetzt schon allen Akteuren der
Branche das sind ihren Planungen davon
ausgehen sollten dass das Verbot am 1
Januar 24 umgesetzt wird nicht das
nachher einer sagt ich wusste es nicht
ich habe jetzt eingekauft oder so dass
mir sehr wichtig dass wir hier auch
verlässlich miteinander sind gerade wenn
wir uns findet differenzierte Lösung
einsetzen bei dem Thema der Richtlinie
in Brüssel und Sie haben ja gehört dass
ich da versuche beide Interessen in
Einklang zu bringen ist es umso
wichtiger dass wir da wo wir wissen
welche drastischen Konsequenzen es für
die biodiver Gebet haben klar sind
so jetzt
kommt Herr Hoffmann noch dran mit einer
weiteren Nachfrage und dann kommen ohne
zweite oder dritte Nachfragen
dran Herr seitler Herr Bär und Frau
lattendorf
frau Präsidentin
das kann ich nicht mehr zulassen einfach
der Zeit halber wir sind eigentlich
schon jetzt nahezu am Ende der Befragung
und deswegen
derzeit wegen der haben Recht dass sich
Herrn Brandner noch einmal recht geben
würde der Zeit wegen insofern muss ich
Sie bitten sich zu setzen gebe Herrn
Hoffmann das Wort und dann so wie es
gerade gesagt habe bitteschön in dem
Fall vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister
Pflanzenschutz ich bin sehr dankbar dass
sie sich bei der EU dafür einsetzen
werden dass auch in den flächenkulissen
Südbadens die Winzer weiter existieren
können das ist eine ganz wichtige
Nachricht sie haben jüngst ein
Exportverbot für Pflanzenschutzmittel
ohne deutsche Zulassung angekündigt und
für mich als entwicklungspolitiker
schrillen da ein bisschen die
Alarmglocken denn für viele
Pflanzenschutzmittel werden in
Deutschland überhaupt keine Zulassung
beantragt weil es die Pflanzen hier
nicht gibt zum Beispiel Bananen oder
eben auch wir haben keine
Heuschreckenschwärme hier die zu
bekämpfen sind da müssen wir Regelungen
treffen dass der globale Süden hier
nicht in den Nachteil kommt was werden
sie tun damit Entwicklungsländer hier
nicht benachteiligt werden bei ihrer
Idee eines exportverbots für
pflanzschutzmittel ja da ich sie am
ersten Punkt beruhigen konnte was die
Richtlinie aus Brüssel angeht hoffe ich
dass es mir auch mit dem zweiten Punkt
gelingt wenn Sie das aufmerksam lesen
was sich da gesagt habe dann spreche ich
extra weil mir der Sachverhalt ja
bekannt ist davon dass Dinge die bei uns
wegen gesundheitlicher Gründe nicht
zugelassen sind dass wir die nicht mehr
exportieren ich glaube da habe ich Ihre
Zustimmung das ist auch ethisch nicht
vertretbar wäre das Dinge die hier
Gesundheitsrisiken auslösen deshalb
nicht zugelassen sind nicht exportiert
werden aber das ist natürlich Produkt
das natürlich Produkte gibt die bei uns
gar keine Zulassung unterliegen weil es
eben hier die Pflanze nicht gibt ist ja
noch mal ein anderer Sachverhalt
Herr Kollege Seidler bitte
er arbeitet oder vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin lieber Minister
selbstständiger ich erlaube mir obwohl
wir uns dem Ende entgegenhagen an etwas
anderes pass auf zu machen sie sind hier
im Haus auch zuständig für einen anderen
Bereich nämlich für den Küstenschutz und
insbesondere den Deichbau wir erleben im
Augenblick dass die nordeuropäischen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dort
nachbessern ausbauen klimateiche
etablieren meine Frage an Sie welche
Pläne hat die Bundesregierung im
Augenblick dort hinterher zu kommen
weiterzuarbeiten wir wissen steigende
Pegelstände Sturmfluten werden zunehmen
wir stehen vor einer riesigen
Herausforderung und danach fragen nicht
erlaubt sind erlauben Sie mir noch eine
Frage hinterher zu schieben es ist im
Augenblick im Innenbereich die
Überlegungen den Bevölkerungsschutz zu
novellieren gibt es dort einen Austausch
zwischen den Ressorts und wäre es sogar
denkbar dass es eine
ressortübergreifende Arbeitsgruppe
Taskforce geben würde die sich diesem
Thema widmet zusammen auch mit den
Kommunen und Ländern die hier ja
Zuständigkeiten haben
letzteres kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen
also wir sind da übers Haus beteiligt
aber was jetzt eine Arbeitsgruppe angeht
das müsste man mit den ressourkollegen
besprechen da bin ich Nachsicht dass die
das glaube ich nicht so prickelnd finden
würden wenn ich das jetzt hier so mal
kurz verkünden würde sondern da werden
wir uns in dem zuständigen Gremium mit
den Kollegen und Kollegen drüber
unterhalten dass der Küstenschutz der
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe auch ist das ist ja
hinreichend bekannt das ist auch für den
Bundesminister ein wichtiges Anliegen da
sind wir im Gespräch auch mit den
Kabinettskollegen wie wir da helfen
können Sie haben recht das ist nicht nur
ein Thema der direkten küsteneiner wir
hatten das heute früh auch im Ausschuss
und da habe ich noch mal ausdrücklich
gesagt das ist auch für die Menschen im
Hinterland ein wichtiges Thema auch da
sind wir im Gespräch
hat keine Nachfrage dazu dann ist jetzt
der Kollege Bär drin
vielen Dank sehr geehrter Minister wenn
wir gerade schon kurz über Glyphosat
gesprochen diese Koalition hat sich ja
wie schon die Vorgänger Regierung auch
im Koalitionsvertrag festgeschrieben das
akakit zu verbieten bis am 1.1.2024 ich
frage mich nun ob die
die Entwicklungen in der EFSA und in
Brüssel daran etwas ändern die dazu
führen dass die Entscheidung auf
Unionsebene erst 2023 fallen wird und
was das Bundesministerium tut um
möglichst eine europäisches Verbot zu
erreichen
also für mich nicht für mich ist völlig
klar der Koalitionsvertrag bindet mich
da auch als Bundesminister übrigens auch
aus tiefste Überzeugung ich setze mich
dafür ein dass wir da eine qualifizierte
Mehrheit in Brüssel bekommen deshalb
habe ich auch gesagt dass ich einer
Verlängerung sehr kritisch gegenüber
stehe und da nicht zugestimmt habe in
Brüssel ich sage aber auch für den Fall
dass es nicht gelingt in Europa sich zu
einigen gilt der Koalitionsvertrag und
werde ich alles tun was nach nationalem
Recht möglich ist um diese
Koalitionsvereinbarung umzusetzen die
Grenzen dessen was sie sagen kennen sie
das ist das europäische Recht das kann
natürlich ein bundesagminister nicht
außer Kraft setzen aber unterhalb der
Schwelle werde ich alles tun was in
meiner legislativen Möglichkeit ist um
das umzusetzen was in der
Koalitionsvereinbarung steht ich glaube
auch da sind die Erkenntnisse der
Auswirkungen auf die Biodiversität ja
sehr deutlich und sehr belegt und das
leitet da unser Handeln
haben sie eine Nachfrage sieht so aus
wird schön
dann ist vor Ladendorf dran
Präsidentin sehr geehrter Minister
am Montag forderten mehr als 300 Kinder
und jugendärzte in einem Appell erneut
das Verbot vom
Marketing von Werbung für ungesunde
Lebensmittel bei Kindern oder für Kinder
allein die Süßwarenindustrie hat ja im
vergangenen Jahr eine Milliarde Euro für
Werbung ausgegeben in diesem Bereich und
das ist ja das falsche Signal für eine
gesunde Ernährung und deswegen meine
Frage werden Sie ein Gesetz auf dem Weg
auf den Weg bringen dass kindermarketing
für gesunde Lebensmittel umfassend im TV
online social media verbieten wird und
wenn es geht noch in diesem Jahr
also sie sprechen etwas an was mir auch
persönlich ein wichtiges Anliegen ist
als zweifacher Vater wenn man einkaufen
geht und weiß was das bedeutet mit einem
kindergerichteter der Werbung aber auch
in den Medien etc das ist Teil unserer
Koalitionsvereinbarung ja das habe ich
fest vor wir arbeiten daran an
kindergerichtete Werbung entsprechend
einzuschränken und wo immer möglich zu
verbieten
da gibt es auch keine Nachfrage mehr in
sofern beende ich hiermit die Befragung
der Bundesregierung Herr öste mir für
die Befragung sind sie jetzt entlassen
und herzlichen Dank dafür und ich komme
zu Tagesordnungspunkt Nummer zwei
nehme ich der Fragestunde ja das waren
sie Übertragung aus dem Bundestag
Befragung der Bundesregierung diesmal
wurde Landwirtschaftsministerium Özdemir
befragt und leider konnten wir aus techn